nearly a dozen high school graduates  accepting apprenticeships at tesla today  it is called  signing day at valley high school a  partnership with tesla where students  take classes  that get them certified in automation  and robotics while they're doing  an apprenticeship at the factory in  northern nevada aidan mckenna  was one of the 11 students accepting  them today and says he's so excited to  start his new life  those are some bright young men and  women and really future  people that will make a big impact in  america's future right yeah and a  wonderful opportunity you know let's  keep them in our state as well  have a good night